what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rid of us
let's just try to get our lunch money
right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent polina
eva luva marinova pompliano
lunch money on a monday night pimp has
stayed
there's nothing better don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block five has three products you
can buy and sell crypto you can deposit
krypton earn
up to 8.6 apy in an interest bearing
account
or you can deposit crypto and take out a
us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
go sign up for a block by account block
five dot com slash pomp
again block fi.com slash pomp
give us the update real quick okay so we
have an
update on the tomato plant if you go
back to an old lunch money you'll see
how sad and dead it was but i
brought it back to life single-handedly
okay
from the dead you're not jesus true life
and hold on we got we got a red one
we got a red we're not supposed to touch
it it kills it no one does it
all right we got a tomato plant
congratulations everyone
let's get into the real show okay ready
so blackrock raised equities to
overweight from neutral
on a six to twelve month tactical basis
i literally have no idea what that means
in its 2021 outlook blackrock also
downgraded global investment grade debt
and u.s treasuries to underweight
so basically the whole idea is that the
firm
believes that the economy will restart
in a powerful manner
yeah basically they think that this is
really gonna start cranking and all of a
sudden
uh stocks are gonna take off even more
there's probably some belief that
there's gonna be another stimulus bill
uh on the horizon so blackrock basically
is making the suggestion
that maybe you should go from neutral on
your stock position to overweight
uh to help catch some of that upside
we'll see what happens
uh yeah they say we see 2021 as a really
powerful year for the restart in terms
of economic activity but also
importantly a year where we're going to
see central banks
hold the interest rates within a pretty
tight range so
okay so is that a v-shaped curve
it's k-shaped right now but the letters
don't matter
the letters don't matter all right next
airbnb
do you remember when we were saying that
like it's kind of like on a more
conservative
um um ipo share situation
well now airbnb boosts the range of its
ipo shares giving it up to a 42 billion
valuations valuation
it it's 56 to 60 per share
and basically they have to keep
increasing the price because there's so
much demand so we'll see what happens
here
so uh okay how long do they have until
like the ipo when is this happening um
i'm not sure oh it's actually for
december 10th
also nasdaq perfect so that's uh later
this week
so yeah damn they don't have that much
time to be changing things anymore
bang bang bang bang okay let's see what
happens let's see what happens
ladies and gentlemen goldman sachs is
weighing plans for a new florida hub
to house one of its divisions and
another potential blow to new york
stature
as the de facto home of the u.s
financial industry
in south florida
now is this for tax advantage purposes
or is this because of
covet it's probably uh it's probably a
lot of different things one there's
definitely tax advantages to operating
your business in florida versus new york
two is there's better weather uh three
is
we have psychopaths that run this city
and state
i mean these people are first class all
right all right we have to get into all
the stuff
they're idiots look okay we can talk
about bill de blasio if you guys want to
talk to tom he now says he's going to
publicly take the vaccine so people
trust me i speak for the people saying
we don't want to hear about this right
now we're talking about goldman sachs
they're moving to florida one of the
reasons they're going to get away from
the fools
uh and then the last thing is um
that there's definitely probably this
sense of uh
covid ask just meaning like can we
actually
get more uh distribution or
decentralization to our offices so not
everyone's in one city in one location
can we actually get a couple of offices
around the country so that it provides a
little bit more
resilience so new york is seeing a
flight of white-collar
jobs from the city manhattan now has the
most
office space available since the
aftermath of september 11th attacks
wow i love it so people are leaving
when you walk out the street there's
nobody else we're still here all right
maybe we won't be lloyd mayweather
will fight social media star logan paul
i had to literally look up you see that
right there
oh that's not how you fight um did you
know did you see that
oh i saw oh i thought it was too quick
you couldn't see it
i had to look up what logan paul looked
like
and i'm here to say i have a feeling
floyd
will take this one home logan paul
is got one shot at winning this fight he
has one
one thing he better come out in the
first round
and just absolutely try to knock this
dude out immediately because if it goes
in a couple of rounds it's over guys we
watched the floyd mayweather
conor mcgregor fight in a upper east
side bar
where it was so packed there was like no
ac i was
sweating to death we were standing up
there were no seats
i mean it was wild and we stayed there
till like one or two am whatever the
it went to and i was like this is i
didn't even get to see a knockout
he was just like all right i quit i
surrender i've
whatever mercy i didn't even get to see
a note it was not very coveted friendly
uh
situation 20 like 17 or 18 next
all right there's this cool family
that survived 40 countries living
solely off of bitcoin for four years
did you know that this is a family of
five use the bitcoin but how do they do
that
they did it they bought clothes toys
oh wait i love it we waited until we
found a person who was willing to accept
bitcoin
for any service wow really they love
bitcoin
they like really love it yeah look part
of this
is uh it's just cool to see uh
people enjoying life who cares about
like the bitcoin thing who cares it's
kind of interesting that the bitcoin
friendly cities were kind of like all in
eastern europe
uh that's not very interesting it's
because literally
all the eastern european cities you know
maybe the people need a little bit more
power to fight back against all the
nonsense the corruption
i wasn't going to say it you did it
because you're from there so you can say
hey hey all right next all right let's
ask lunch money time we went
fast today man um
all right so d doan asks
pomp i was not aware of everly well
until six minutes ago
how did you learn about it this is uh
the testing
company that is now valued at one
billion dollars is there a website or
company that you can research for
private companies such as everly well to
invest
uh basically no um
it's all through like relationships so
uh everly well the founder julia cheek
she knew somebody who knew my partner
jason
uh and that person was like hey should
talk to jason because jason previously
built the healthcare company
so that's how we found that one but
that's pretty much how we find all the
companies like
some yeah somebody will say hey you
should talk to these people or i'll like
call a bunch of friends i know that are
investing i'm like hey what are you
seeing
so that i'm constantly seeing as many
deals uh
as i possibly can and uh yeah go from
there
think first hey pomp is there anyone who
you really want to interview but didn't
get the chance to
and who was your favorite interview um
favorite interview
i all right i'm just going to say it i'm
trying to get edward snowden wait wait
no i'm trying to get edward snowden
it's not necessarily like he's the one
that would be like my number one pick in
the world to interview
but i do think that it would be
fascinating to talk to him
uh so i am uh nicely
dming him edward if you're watching
please respond to my dms
but who has been your favorite interview
uh i did an interview where i just
talked by myself
nah that was polina she knows well
actually we have a new one coming out
this
thursday right where i talk about all
the things i've learned from doing the
profile dossier you should check it out
all right final question which is a good
one from
oh shoot did i not get oh from jason
jason truman
he asks okay he just saw digital art
sell for 1.1
bitcoin yesterday fiwo fawoshes her art
sold for how much
in a digital art it's over 21 000
he's fascinated by this jason is i was a
professional musician for 25 years until
covet hit
i've been unemployed since march due to
my venues being closed my question is
can you please explain the value in this
digital art
and mainly how do i take my original
music compositions
which are also digital art and
incorporate my music skills into the
crypto world
basically just think of a
file whether it has art it has words
it has music whatever it's just computer
file and
what these nfts allow you to do is prove
originality
and scarcity and so therefore the
digital art
just like if i had a original pablo
picasso
on the wall oh you would know that
that's pablo picasso but is it original
or is it not
well if it was an original the owner of
the piece would definitely tell you
of course but like the people who own
the fakes also tell you they're original
sometimes
and so the whole key is when you
want to prove scarcity or prove
originality it's very hard to do in the
traditional world
with digital art uh it's very easy to do
uh because you can literally see kind of
the um
provenance of who owns it and who has
owned it in the past and then also the
art because in a digital format can do
all kinds of things that you can't do in
the traditional world so
it can have motion it can have sound it
can do all these different things
there's a lot of people
um uh i'm going to say
wow i think is how you pronounce it but
i had him on the podcast he's fantastic
i'm really really impressed with him but
it's like 3
lau um is a dj and
uh he's been creating all kinds of nfts
with sound uh this guy scott melker i
think it's done a couple with sound and
art
um in these nfts so uh i would go check
out
non-fungible token and so
how can music play in this world well
music goes into the art so like if you
imagine
when you play a video you can put motion
you put sound you can do all these
things and wrap it into one uh same
thing here with digital artwork
so that could be interesting like do you
see artists partnering with other
artists like music artists with like
art artists and putting together the
music and the
that's what they're doing that's really
cool yeah so jason
maybe find yourself a digital artist you
can partner with
at ferocious at ferocious let's go okay
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five so go check them out there's a link
in the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind paulina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends